[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[تصفيق] يقضي
الجميع وقتًا ممتعًا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى
] ليست حتى الساعة الثامنة
] الشمس مشرقة والطقس
رائع وقبل 10 دقائق فقط  كان
المطر يتساقط من المطر ،
لقد زرت دبلن مرات
عديدة على مر السنين ، ومثل الآخرين ، لدي بعض
الأفكار المسبقة عن التقاليد
والكلمات المبتذلة التي
أتطلع إليها حقًا على الرغم من
هذه الزيارة لأنني سمعت أن هناك
روحًا جديدة في  دوبلين
[موسيقى
] أحب الطريقة التي
يمكن السير بها في دبلن واتبع النهر ولا يمكنني أن
أخطئ ، لقد تغيرت دبلن كثيرًا منذ
إطلاقها كنمر سلتيك في
بقية أوروبا
الآن مثل بقية أنحاء العالم دبلن في
الواقع
يبحث بحذر شديد عن غرض ما بعد الجائحة وهو
يقف على النهر ، يمكنك رؤية
القديم والجديد ، دبلن التقليدي
هناك مع دار الجمارك
وأبراج التمويل الجديدة والرافعات التي
تظهر تزداد
حجمًا وتمسك بقبعتك بذلك  نسيم
قادم
في الماء  r على وشك أن يصبح
سيئًا وسألتجئ إلى حانة
يوجد منها بالطبع العديد منها في
الواقع ليست مجرد حانة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى
] الحصى
الذي يسمونه أنفسهم حانة للشرب بها
مشكلة موسيقية
توماس موليجان  وكانت العائلة
مضيفة لي منذ عام 1987.
جاء والدي إلى هنا وكان هناك
زبائن قاسيون للغاية كان أه هنا
في الوقت الذي تعرف أنه كان منزلًا مبكرًا ،
وهذا يعني أن الأشخاص
الذين كانوا يعملون في نوبات ليلية
لقد
أتيت مباشرة بعد الانتهاء من العمل
وهذيًا بالتعب ثم
بدأ يومًا في الشرب فوق
ذلك وبعد فترة قرر للتو أنه
يريد إصلاح ذلك تمامًا
وتشغيل الموسيقى كل يوم من أيام الأسبوع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى
]  مئات المنازل العامة في
دبلن ، لقد اخترت هذا الحجر
لأنه موطن
الموسيقى الأيرلندية التقليدية وقد فازت للتو بمعركة قانونية من
أجل البقاء ،
صدق أو لا تصدق ، أنت تعرف أن هذه
عاصمة الأمة أه هذا بين
الشيء الذي نشتهر به هو
موسيقانا ، لا يوجد العديد من الأماكن التي
يمكنك الذهاب إليها بالفعل والتفاعل مع هذا
الجانب من ثقافتنا هنا على أساس يومي
[موسيقى]
نحب أن يترك الناس
هذا المكان في حالة أفضل مما
جاؤوا  يوجد فينا
طرق يمكن
تحسينها حقًا ، هناك أفعال موجودة
بالفعل ولكن هناك الكثير من الأشخاص يأتون إلى
هنا ولا يشربون حتى مشروبًا كما
تعلمون وهذا هو الشيء المميز في هذا
المكان
[الموسيقى]
ننظر في أعماق وجوه هؤلاء
الموسيقيون هم موسيقى الموسيقى التي
يبدعونها ، وبالطبع أريد أن
أذهب ،
ولكن ما هي الآلة التي يجب أن تعزفها
الآن ، ويجب عليك التبديل في
كل مكان تذهب إليه في أيرلندا ، فهذا
سيضمن لك طردك من كل
بوب لك  الذهاب إلى
ذلك ، هل الأمر بهذه الطريقة
ليس لي أن أعلمك أنه من
أجل كين
مدرس محترف ،
سيعلمك كل شيء عن ذلك
سيعلمني عنه لأنني أتطلع
إلى تعلم التطلع إلى تحسين  ص  ythm
قليلاً ، لذا سنذهب إلى إيقاعي غير
موجود
واحد اثنان ثلاثة أربعة واحد نعم
وضربه بشدة على واحد لأسفل لأعلى ، انقر فوق
واحد اثنين ثلاثة أربعة
مثل البطيخ البطيخ البطيخ هي
طريقة سهلة لتذكرها ، لذلك بالنسبة
للرقص ، إنها ريش  والنقانق ،
لذا لا يمكنني الغناء أو العزف على أي آلة موسيقية ولكن هذا لا يهم
[الموسيقى]
[تصفيق].
امنعني من الانضمام إلى لعبة Bowron
لأن هذا هو كل ما يدور حوله هذا المكان
أنه معدي ، إنه ما يصفه
السكان المحليون هنا بأنه جزء من
الكراك
[الموسيقى]
تهجئته أو أراه
، إنه مجرد شعور بأنك
تعلم أن الكراك يبلغ 90  المصداقية التي
تتطاير بها الكراك تتطاير ،
إنها مجرد ضجة ، إنها ضجة ،
إنه شعور يمكنك الشعور به في
أعماق روحك ، يمكنك الشعور به
في عظامك في النخاع ،
إنه كهربائي تمامًا
[تصفيق]
لقد دخلت في ر  إنه
حانة وأشعر أن الكراسي والطاولات
تشبه الارتفاع على بعد بوصة واحدة
من الأرض ، فأنت تعلم أن شيئًا ما على
وشك الانطلاق هنا وسيكون رائعًا